alors gilles verdez alors mathieu je
suis venu ce soir parce que l'attaquant
la séquence n'était pas du tout prévu
donc sur
mes lacets gauche vois tu crois tu
racontes n'importe quand j'attendais ce
moment attaquants mais depuis quand vous
avez la prendre des mois
je suis hyper sérieux c'est un vrai truc
donc il se passe quelque chose entre
mathieu et moi depuis l'année dernière
que vous allez découvrir aussi tout est
à mykonos
mais c'est grave c'est que on ne se
parle plus on se dit même plus bonjour
jeune diplômé plus on attendait parce
que février sur une séquence d'art car
il est 19 heures et sur une séquence la
séquence n'était pas du tout prêt non je
veux changer si vous volez non non non
on est on dit tous d'accord alors gilles
ouais je ne sais pas mathieu dont vous
parlez plus populaires marié parlant de
gilles s accroît que mathieu est choisi
gilles michael sheen
c'est beau à l'eau c'est fou on est
bénie des dieux
c'est vrai tous avec une régie comme ça
il ya pas de séquences vous sentez
canard une
ça bouge pas
on a un fort ressentiment l'un pour
l'autre en tout cas moi j'en ai un je
pense qu'il est partagée c'est depuis la
polémique de l'année dernière sur
raciste homophobe etc j'ai totalement
coupé les ponts avec mathieu je ne lui
parle plus je lui dis plus bonjour je
n'évite pas en loge mais je le regarde
dans les yeux et ensuite je me détourne
donc je pense que peut-être si mathieu
accepté de lever le rideau ce serait le
moment que tu as quelque chose que je
lui dise quelque chose après attend de
moi ce que là tu l'as toujours pas ni
s'est il agacé le constat
c'est le constat donne déjà les doigts
maintenant est-ce que tu ouvres
la braguette de gilles
rideau
c'est un autre concept quand même oui
c'est vrai c'est que tu ouvres norgil a
quelque chose à dire ce que tu as envie
de l'entente de magna j'entends la
méthode aba fallait entendre avant
d'ouvrir et a choisi ouais j'entends
bravo non mais en tout cas fait six
mois qu'on dit même pas bonjour non mais
si fous je ne savais pas du tout normal
mais pas et mathieu est ce que tu as
envie d'entendre que gilles à te dire
vous kribi tout à fait et ça pas
d'ouvrir la vidéo alors attendrait pas
exactement pour l'instant il l'entend
j'entends célébrer écoute toi t'as
comtois tu as compris concept a bien sûr
les petites trois mois
la perla nera compris pensé que ça
allait se porter
quoi pour une fois que je me trompe
comme vous êtes trompés ou en annonçant
déclamer les images de tintin écoute moi
qui ait autant de soutiens gorge
l'au-delà
qui est ainsi la
pile non mais il ya quelque chose quand
même on en rigole parce qu'on me
détendre l'atmosphère un vrai truc mais
c'est un vrai truc et je m'attendais pas
à ça comme disait patrick bruel
c'est une chanson de brel bah oui je
m'attendais pas à toi tu attendais pas
toi m'attendais pas à ça attendez pas à
toi
et la couche
abrogera gil j 1 dans une volonté
potentiel de réconciliation donc va
doucement mathieu parce que je peux me
voilà alors j'ai des rations il va
toujours doucement
il ya quelques années on a une brouille
violence brouille et tu as fait le
premier pas que venu vers moi pour me
parler pour qu'on se réconcilie ce soir
je suis venu tu as accepté d'ouvrir le
rideau n'en faire le premier pas ça fait
après tu décides la banque en valeur des
six même page principale de l'émission
s'il écoute on est dans l'émotion de
penser qu'en mai la norme il arrivera
prix va dire si nous voulons rien
absolument alors j'espère que tu
ouvriras le rideau ça fait des mois
qu'on ne se parle plus je pense que le
moment est venu de se reparler de tirer
ça au clair moi je vais te dire tu as
été très violent tuent m'a blessé mais
moi aussi sans doute donc nous sommes
tous les deux blessés comme on absorbe
personnalités l'enseignement qu'on en a
tiré ses boycottons nous toi tu mouilles
coach de boycott j'ai envie que tu ouvre
le rideau pour venir vers toi si jamais
tu l'ouvrés de serrer la main et te dire
repartons sur de bonnes bases revenons à
m'y attendais il a dit ce qu'il avait
dit
mathieu
cette séquence est vrai n'était pas
prévu je retiens gilles et pas un truc
là
témoins tibet de musicale ce choix sont
tenus devant mathieu
les images sont nuls devant toi bah oui
mais bon
mathieu
gilles
a fait un
pas vers toi et d'amis comme disait jean
pierre mader un piéton
sentence ira demain
mathieu je sais que
ça tu avais énormément affecté ce qui
s'était passé l'an dernier mais gilles
c'est quelqu'un qu'on aime ici c'est
vrai qu'on est une famille avec des
disputes des joies des peines
et vacances à mykonos
mais mathieu
moi je ne te force serait jamais à
parler un des chroniqueurs et je ne
savais pas que tu ne parlais pas à
gilles depuis ce moment là ça fait
combien de temps maintenant ça fait
peut-être cinq mois ouais cinq mois
qu'ils ne se parlent de six mois sept
mois non non un enfant quoi ça fait un
enfant qui n'est pas pas neuf mois
beaucoup vous avez accouché
de d'un beau bébé
mathieu est ce que tu acceptes d'ouvrir
le rideau
et de serrer la main de gilles et de
repartir sur des bases saines
c'est ce que tu veux gillot oui je
l'espère oui je fais un geste un premier
pas j'espère voilà
battue je te laisse réfléchir non
réfléchir et non pas réfléchi me dire te
rafraîchir l matthieu delormeau est face
à un dilemme un dilemme
d'amour ou d'amitié
ils pensent à moi je le vois je le sens
je le sais et son sourire ne ment pas
quand il vient me chercher pouces il
aime bien me parler les choses qu'il a
vues du chemin qu'il a fait et de tous
ces projets est là non pas une référence
hétéro
mathieu des fouets gilles a tendu la
main
est-ce que tu décides d'ouvrir le rideau
et de repartir à zéro avec gillot
je peux je peux dire tu peux tout nous
dire ici tu es en confiance avec tes
amis je suis d'ordinaire pas rancunier
mais là je n'ouvre pas de rideaux tous
les cas pas maintenant parce que
j'attendais de gilles c'est vrai depuis
six mois à défaut d'excusés au moins des
regrets rien est arrivé or il sait très
bien la raison de notre brouille allait
quand même très violente et donc
je n'ai jamais compris pendant six mois
il n'est jamais eu la délicatesse au
moins si le fasse pas l'antenne
peut-être dans les coulisses de venir
s'excuser ou encore une fois j'ai dit
exprimer des regrets parce qu'on va pas
revenir sur le sujet mais il était il
était très dur doublement dur pour moi
donc
bah je vais chez bayer habsi qui m'avait
dit pour qui et pardon faut qu'il y ait
réparation
il n'y a pas eu réparation il y aura pas
pardon donc il faut que shilpa shetty
exactement speedy du du coeur donc là tu
as besoin de temps
bah ça viendra de lui peut-être celle là
là ce qui m'a dit c'est très gentil mais
il va nouveau pad excuse rien du tout
pour lui c'est repartons à zéro ben non
gilles pour repartir à zéro il aurait il
eu fallu qu'on soit qui n'était pas le
cas c'est toi qui être tenu des propos
blessants c'est pas moi donc je peux
vous acceptez peut-être de d'aller
prendre un verre tous les deux et c'est
moi qui paieraient l'orangina csa-le
bien
non mais ce qui me dérange c'est dans ce
qu'il a dit à nouveau là ils n'y ont
fait la paix mais
je ne ressens aucun lien aucun regret
sur ce niveau on passe pas un coup
d'épongé sur des choses aussi
importantes gênerait pas ce que j'ai dit
mais je me pose et vanilla je regrette
de l'avoir blessée voilà ce vol on s'est
dit des choses violentes 1 et l'autre je
regrette de l'avoir blessée c'était beau
de ma demande je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
de rejoindre est pire que tout moi je
leur ai pas dit non mais c'est dû à là
c'est quand je crois vraiment à la
séquence n'est pas prévu là tu crois
vraiment maintenant retourner à deux
tours de chant chercher la casse annoncé
que des archives il ya une fille qui
s'occupe d'énergie si tu veux la paix
[Applaudissements]
pour rien la vérité je continue de
penser je suis pas producteur c'est un
excellent chroniqueur et je trouve
excellente et psp mais c'est vrai que
quand le l'instant lettre j'ai envie de
voir voilà pour l'instant pour l'instant
pour l'instant on ira horaire à venir
pour l'instant bien sûr tôt demain matin
tout n'est pas fermée tout n'est pas
fermé aux jo c'est que chez vous tout
n'est pas faire non non non je sais
c'est très bien d'ailleurs très bien
bravo gilles bravo voilà parce que non
mes films
on va voir ce que j'aime voilà c'est que
ici voilà oui ça triche pas non mathieu
il aurait très bien pu pour le show
d'hier willaya gilles et ce n'était pas
du tout prévu à paris il a parlé avec
son coeur voilà donc bravo à tous les
deux voilà pour vrai jespere pourrait
considérer bientôt et voilà si vous avez
besoin bien sûr de d'un d'un petit coup
de pouce un tipi restait comme ça tu
regardes ce qui reste aux autres comme
ça pour aller là c'est plus facile
autour d'un dîner qu'autour d'un verre
alors un dîner moi je veux bien mais je
ne paierai dollars week-end le week-end
pour se la réintégration week-end de
radio canada ont fermé gardent leur
rideau fermé
[Applaudissements]